My name is Tumeletso Setlabosha.
But people call me…
Water.
I live in the center of the Okavango Delta.
It's wonderful.
As a young man, I was a tracker,
helping people to hunt wildlife.
Elephant footprint. It came from this way.
Five Zebras!
But now I use my skills as a guide.
The Okavango Delta is protected,
and people in Botswana can benefit from
a conservation-based tourism economy.
Our communities thrive because people come
from all over the world to see our wildlife.
Mr. Water belongs to one of
many communities who rely on the water
that begins thousands of kilometers north in Angola.
But upstream,
local people don’t benefit from
the same sustainable livelihoods.
There used to be a lot of animals here before…
elephants, lions, rhinos…
Now hunting has become a vice in this territory.
Like Mr. Water,
Elias lives from what the Okavango Basin provides.
But overhunting, deforestation
and unchecked commercial agriculture
are putting the source waters of the Delta at risk,
leaving not only Elias’ livelihood at stake,
but also a million other people living across
Angola, Namibia, and Botswana.
We’d prefer to stop hunting
so as not to destroy the lives of living things.
Working with Elias, Mr.  Water,
and many others across the region,
National Geographic and De Beers
through their Okavango Eternal partnership
will support community-based conservation
and help ensure that land is protected.
Cooperatives, local community training,
and support for sustainable agriculture
and small business development
all contribute to local communities prospering
in harmony with nature
as their stewardship safeguards
the future of the entire Okavango System.